not what I had in mind when we said we
should hit the town this might be a late
night sorry I'm late the curls were not
cooperating this morning hope you had a
light breakfast it's my girlfriend she
could summon the power and it's up to us
to protect the city
now on I only do go ahead fire away
might have the weight of the whole city
falls on my shoulders
now does everybody lost their minds
hey everybody new footage from all the
shows I'm mostly going to focus on the
flash stuff and we got some confirmation
on which versions of which flash
characters are coming back this season
so they're gonna be a bunch of team
flash changes that I'll explain but I'll
start with the footage first there's
really just a couple new scenes they
splice in here and it's mostly of Barry
after he's come back and things have
gone back to relatively normal whatever
you think normal is for team flash just
him joking about eating a really big
breakfast with all kinds of pancakes
remember he has a crazy metabolism cisco
makes a joke about his hair that's
really about it there isn't too many
revealing things about this they're just
certainly to get you hyped up for the
season they dropped this when they were
dropping all those previews a couple
days ago I already did one for that
special flash preview so I had a link
for that at the end of this if you're
new to the channel to I do flash ring
giveaway every week I usually announce
giveaway winners at the end of videos so
the big thing here is the team flash is
changing a little bit without changing
too much like this will sound a little
familiar where they keep most of their
main cast people have different powers
and we found out which version of
Harrison wells is gonna come on John
Wesley Shipp was talking about some
funny Jay Garrick stuff too that you
guys will really like it was a big flash
arrow panel at Dragon Con this past
weekend so they had reverse-flash they
had Jay Garrick they had Barry's mom
there was even Katie Cassidy from arrow
so there was a bunch of actors that were
just talking about stuff for the next
season but starting with the new team
flash changes so what'll happen is is
they'll be a bunch of changes for the
first couple of episodes and then
they'll change a little bit more as new
characters get cycled in like official
team flash members then there's the
unofficial team flash members like [ __ ]
who will still be around so I'll try to
explain the difference and like how the
dynamic is changing in which characters
will be coming in so you've seen the
trailer for the first episode that
pretty much explains the dynamic Wally's
running point
iris becomes the woman in the chair ned
leads spider-man homecoming style
normally that'd be cisco he'd be yelling
into Barry's ears he was running around
saving people but the thing is is now
that cisco is like full-on vibe he's out
helping people like Kid Flash who's
running point so that means that they
need a new support person back it's
our labs talking into people's ears and
they don't have Harrison wells back
right away
we have hybrid Frost I'll just call her
that for now because she's walking
around looking like Caitlin but she
still has her killer frost powers they
were just finishing filming episode four
a little while ago and she was on set as
full-blown killer frost and it didn't
look like it was a flashback but it
could be a flashback there was this
person posting with her so she has the
makeup on they haven't explained why she
switches from one to the other if it's a
conscious choice or if it's something
that happens on accident because she has
that choker that probably has something
to do with her changing because she's
not wearing the choker now while she's
killer frost but then as you know Barry
comes back right at the end of episode
one beginning of episode two his mind
might still be a little bit fuzzy he
said that when he first came back out of
the Speed Force that he would be a
little bit weird so eventually he takes
point that probably happens at some
point during episode two then we get
Harrison wells back and it sounds like
he's confirmed to be the earth 2 version
of Harrison wells so you can call him
Harry call him whatever you want I just
think of him as Harrison wells and I
called earth 19 Harrison wells HR so HR
died at the end of last season he's not
coming back
earth to Harrison wells has been on his
home planet while Jesse quick has been
on earth 3 helping Jay Garrick protect
that earth so it gets a little more
complicated here so I'll explain Jay
Garrick earth 3 stuff in a second but
the thing with Harrison wells is that
he's basically by himself on earth -
they don't need a flash there because
everything is actually going really well
so he's getting really bummed out and he
needs to find new purpose with his life
so that's what causes him to come back
to team flash if the producers said that
he's sort of rediscovering his purpose
now that he's saved Jessie quick like
the whole thing the first couple seasons
was protecting his daughter and now that
he sort of backed off of that a little
bit he needs to find something else to
live for and that'll be tied up in the
fight against the thinker this season so
I think that's interesting because
usually when you think about the big
villains arc usually think about it as
sort of like the mirror for the heroes
arc which is usually Barry but it'll
also have a lot to do with Harrison
wells from earth-2 as far as we know
Jessie quick doesn't come back right
away but she'll probably
show up a little bit during the first
half of the season she hasn't been
around that much because the actress who
plays her has been traveling all over
the world for the last month or so so if
she's off somewhere else she can't be
filming flash episodes so I'm not
expecting her right away
it sounds like her and Wally are still
doing the long-distance relationship
thing Jay Garrick is a little more of a
question mark I'm expecting him to show
up at least as much as he showed up last
season which was only for a couple
episodes but at DragonCon you guys think
this is funny
he said that if you want to see Jay
Garrick in that 90s flash costume again
make sure you tweet about it because
back during season two when they were
traveling to earth-2 for the first time
they actually showed an alternate earth
with John Wesley Shipp in his 90s flash
costume
it was literally a frame taken from the
90s flash show it wasn't present-day
John Wesley Shipp wearing the costume it
was him from back in the 90s so I think
the idea is is that in this multiverse
even though he played Barry on the 90s
series is that if we see the 90s flash
costume come back it'll be an alternate
version of Jay Garrick but he's like if
you want to see it make sure you tweet
about it so these are the people that
you can tweet at if you want to see that
90s flash costume show up but also on
that same panel reverse-flash said that
he basically wants reverse-flash to come
back and have an episode with himself
like literally go to another version of
you bar thought and then just interact
with each other because the character is
so narcissistic like he's like this
would be very self-serving
but I really want you Bart Thawne to
meet another version of eobard thawne
which sounds about right
he of course didn't spoil how perverse
flash is going to come back or when he's
gonna come back I think they want to
roll in all these new changes to the TV
show because there's sort of soft
rebooting it and I think second half of
the season is probably when we'll see
reverse flash comeback but then the last
real big team flash member like official
team flash member is gonna be elongated
man he won't show up to like middle of
the first half of the season and then
that'll be part of the big thinker art
like don't be surprised if elongated man
is on some sort of hunt because he's a
detective in the comics for the thinker
and Barry's separately doing the same
thing and then they realized that and
sort of come together
but in the way that they always pick up
new people like Julian that's like the
next new team flash member as far as I
know it'll just be him sue did knee
won't be married to him when we first
meet him because they're all relatively
young on the TV show even Barry and iris
haven't gotten married yet but actually
Diggle from eros spoiled a little bit
about the wedding's that are happening
this season he joked that there might be
two weddings but Barry and iris are
definitely going to get married so I'll
talk about that in a second too and then
on top of all that you probably saw the
danny trejo pictures so he's playing
breacher who is gypsies father a villain
from the comics he was bigger during the
new 52 and I think we actually even hear
Cisco yelling about him in that first
trailer that we saw back at Comic Con
but I can't remember the last time the
Danny Trejo played a character that
wasn't a badass so it sounds like he's
gonna kick a whole bunch of team flash
ass
his powers are just like a bigger
version of the stuff that Cisco and
[ __ ] are able to do but hopefully that
explains a little bit about who team
flash is going to be this season how
iris will be the new woman in the chair
while Cisco's out running around with
everybody until Barry comes back and
runs point wally will be running point
he's even gonna be in the old Barry
costume for a little while then it
sounds like he goes back to the old
yellow costume Barry's gonna be wearing
his future flash costume and then really
the other big question is is what will
elongated man's powers look like when he
comes on the show because it sounds like
it'd be really expensive to have him
stretching all the time but let me know
what you guys think about all this and
let me know what you think about Jay
Garrick in that 90's flash costume and
there's a new type of video that I want
to try to do this year it's really just
like a new version of the QA videos that
I used to do for flash and arrow but now
because there are so many DC TV shows
it's getting hard to do videos for
everything so I figure doing at least
one DC TV Q&A video each week would
solve some of those problems but if
you've seen my Game of Thrones videos
you know how I do the top 10 Q&A video
imagine me just doing a version of that
for all the DC TV stuff that happens
each week but I can't really try that
out until episode start dropping so just
let me know if that's the kind of video
that you guys would be interested in but
either way it'll be fun so what'll
happen later tonight is I have new Game
of Thrones suppose leave all your DC TV
video requests in the comments below
don't worry all this stuff is coming
back really soon and I almost forgot the
wedding stuff so Diggle from arrow was
saying that we might actually see that
Barry iris wedding in the big four night
crossover this season so that doesn't
really answer the question as to what
the story is gonna be so when I hear
some more information about that I'll
totally do a video about it but
congratulations to the new giveaway
winner Col Clark please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details while you
wait for everything you can click here
for brand new flash and you can click
here for brand new Game of Thrones thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight